the launch of the family section on
Google Play was hugely positive four
story toys I think what it did was solve
the discovery issue for parents it's
really provided a safe trusted creative
space for families to find new content
my partner guy orany when I started baby
first with the idea and a passion to
create good educational content for
babies toddlers and their parents when
we learned about a family category on
the Google Play Store it was a hundred
percent match to the baby first values
we have seen that parents can easily
find the content they are looking for we
now have 40% more downloads on Google
Play than we do on other platforms you
like that since the launch of the family
section on Google Play our experience
with Android has been completely
transformed we saw huge uplift in
revenues and downloads to Google Play
was now a number one channel it's been
nothing but positive were delighted to
be involved